from almond moms to ingredient only
households the world is finally ready to
unearth their childhood food trauma and
unpack the origins of their problematic
relationship with food for the past year
Tick Tock has been buzzing about these
Boomer parenting tropes with hundreds of
content creators commenting on how their
childhood experiences around the dinner
table sparked a long life of food and
body distrust I think a lot of us can
relate So today we're going to unpack
our food history together and give you
some better guidance on what you should
do if you've been a victim of childhood
food trauma hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
in today's video we'll be talking about
how your childhood and familial
experiences can shape your relationship
with food but first you can pause the
screen or look at my description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning that we will be
discussing some pretty problematic diet
culture behaviors and recommendations so
please feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey I
also want to acknowledge that the
development of disordered eating eating
disorders and overeating Tendencies are
highly complex and multifactorial so I
am by no means suggesting that these
childhood experiences or a particular
parenting style or parenting Choice
results in an eating disorder nor am I
shaming parentses who have engaged in
some of these behaviors ultimately they
likely were victims of dye culture
themselves but a quick reminder guys if
you're not subscribed help your girl out
hit that subscribe button and follow me
over on Tick Tock and Instagram Abby's
kitchen for lots more really great
evidence based content if you're
currently struggling with your
relationship with food you're going to
want to listen up let's talk about these
struggles of us Millennials and gen Z's
who grew up in these Health obsessed
homes
[Applause]
a couple of almonds chew them really
well because your your stomach is hot
this is the hardest from being on our
diet
leave it to Yolanda create a whole genre
of parenting that Tick Tock is going
wild about right now but thanks to this
clip going viral loads of scarred
Millennials and gen Z's have been
sharing their experiences growing up
with a so-called almond mom if you
missed it the Almond mom is notoriously
obsessed with dieting in the pursuit of
Fitness so think about yolan Hadid
telling your daughter Gigi to eat a
carrot instead of her own birthday cake
or the moms that always would chant a
moment on the lips Forever on the hips
anytime a donut came near
total Binger April this is going to go
straight to your ass in short almond
moms are obsessed with weight loss and
dieting at any cost often under the
guise of wellness and health now
ingredient only households are another
big topic of conversation right now
which is basically a commentary on homes
that only buy ingredients to make
specific meals in some cases this may be
rooted in True Food insecurity where
parents are trying to make the most out
of their grocery budget now obviously
food insecurity in childhood absolutely
can increase the risk of Eating
Disorders relating to food hoarding
sneaking and overeating with one study
suggesting that food insecurity increase
the risk of binge eating by 40 percent
but I'm gonna put that aside right now
because food insecurity isn't exactly a
behavior that we can necessarily choose
to change so let's talk about the other
potential scenario where adults create
ingredient only households to Bar their
kids access to perceived junk or highly
processed snack foods and some might say
hey this is a smart way to reduce waste
packaging and
sure in a perfect world wherever
every time an excellent food skills yeah
you're probably right but what would I
do if I was hungry for a snack while
short on time yet everything in the
house would require at least 30 minutes
prep time I would probably skip the
snack I would probably eat less even
though my body was asking for fuel for a
lot of us busy normal folks convenience
foods help us nourish our bodies with
the fuel it needs so if the covert
intention is to get our kids or us to
eat less or to eat less of what we
perceive to be bad kids will figure this
out we will figure this out food
restriction even outside the context of
weight loss as we so often see in
Wellness culture can be incredibly
damaging long term whether we're talking
unhealthy boxed mac and cheese for the
Almond moms or even healthy store-bought
granola bars for our ingredient only
households kids who grow up being told
they can't have something because it's
bad are likely to become adults with
problematic relationships with these
forbidden foods and it can be a really
hard cycle to break but what
about when the Restriction is less
sneaky what about when we're talking
about your parental role model embarking
on an intentional weight loss Journey
with the kids watching on the sidelines
for Mom specifically we know that
maternal concerns about their body and
weight is the third leading cause of
body image problems amongst young
children one study found that pre-teens
and teens who believed that weight and
being thin was important to their moms
were two to three times more likely to
have significant weight concerns and
loads more research confirms that
children of moms who restrict food or
calories are more likely to experience
negative body image poor self-esteem
disordered eating and become chronic
dieters themselves it's also worth
noting that even if dieting mothers do
not explicitly impose their lifestyle
onto their children by restricting their
Foods even the act of just role modeling
these behaviors can be damaging tell me
if any of these ring a bell did your
parent ever eat a different diet meal or
avoid the unhealthy meal components that
she or he was serving the rest of the
family did your parents say oh I've been
so bad today for eating pizza for lunch
and then proceed to order something
super Locale or skip the meal altogether
did they ever miss out on family time to
exercise to make up for something that
they ate did they ever casually
criticize their own body or make
critical comments or jokes about other
people's bodies and did they ever label
certain foods as good and other Foods as
bad even if just in the context of their
own plate chances are you've been
exposed to behaviors in language just
like this and as an adult you've
probably engaged in some of it yourself
and I'm not judging again this way of
talking and thinking about food and our
body is grossly ingrained in our culture
it's celebrated it is the norm it is
very hard to escape but we are the most
important people in our kids lives and
like sponges they will suck up anything
and everything that we say even if it
feels like we're doing our best to be
sneaky and keep it to ourselves sneaky
sneaky sir so we know that being on a
diet ourselves can poison future food
relationships and that even
participating in more covert forms of
dye culture AKA Wellness culture can
also do harm but you know what's
potentially even more risky forcing our
kids to participate in these behaviors
in the explicit pursuit of childhood
weight loss let's talk about putting
kids on a diet there's no question that
weight stigma and dieting in childhood
can have long-term Health implications
and Jonah Hill's recent Netflix
documentary stunts does a really great
job of articulating exactly that in the
doc Jonah shares his experience
experiences as an overweight child
feeling pressured by his doctor mother
and Society at large to lose weight he
says that exercise and diet was framed
to him as there's something wrong with
how you look and this ultimately led him
to develop a turbulent relationship with
food and his body and he even avoided
exercise as an adult due to the negative
associations that he developed with it
as a child Jonah later sat down with his
mother to share his experiences of being
prescribed weight loss as a kid and she
admitted that her approach just stemmed
from her own childhood where her mother
would make fat phobic comments about her
weight so no shade to Jonah's mom like
she was just doing what she was taught
herself using the best tools that she
was given when she was growing up but
Jonah and his mom's experiences are
really not unique with research
suggesting that kids whose parents
encourage them to diet were more likely
to encourage their own kids to do the
same same it's a toxic generational
cycle but again when we know better we
can do better and we know that research
consistently shows that children put on
diets are more likely to become
overweight or obese as adults and are
more likely to suffer from lower
self-esteem body dissatisfaction and
depression as is the case with Jonah it
also can result in hating Health
promoting behaviors in Foods because of
the deep-seated trauma that they now
associate with them not to mention
children are undergoing rapid growth and
development they need time and patience
to settle into their body's natural set
point undisturbed dieting during these
critical growth years can not only
increase the risk of nutrient
deficiencies but it can also put kids at
risk of menstrual regularity or
amenorrhea osteoporosis and iron
deficiency anemia which can ultimately
Impact Physical and cognitive growth and
future learning outcomes unfortunately
despite so much data demonstrating
significant risks of putting kids on
diets during these uniquely sensitive
times in their lives the controversial
new American Academy of Pediatrics
statement on childhood obesity has made
best practices really really difficult
to establish the new guidelines are
recommending that kids as young as six
be treated with intensive health
behavior and lifestyle treatment to
reduce their BMI kids 12 and up to start
Weight Loss drugs potentially and that
kids as young as 13 who are at or above
120th percent of the 95th percentile be
referred for weight loss surgery surgery
at 13 when their body is rapidly growing
and changing
oh
rightfully so a lot of the medical
community has been pushing back hard on
these recommendations because they're
now basically focusing exclusively on
the treatment of obesity rather than the
prevention and a lot of these
recommendations are known to do harm in
fact they directly contradict the
recommendations in their own guidelines
for preventing obesity and eating
disorders in adolescence like Mecca
makes sense nothing makes sense listen
as a fellow parent I get that ensuring
our kids are healthy is our top priority
I also fully understand the importance
of maintaining a healthy body weight I'm
not denying the risks of obesity here
but weight is not the only indicator of
good health and health is also about
more than just physical health we need
to weigh the emotional and psychological
toll of these suggestions as well not to
mention as I discussed childhood
restriction can actually increase the
risk of adult obesity so it's not
necessarily fixing the problem long term
so while I believe that balancing the
risks and benefits of dieting or
intentional weight loss can be tricky
business for anyone I really truly
firmly believe that it should be met
with Extreme Caution in kids and teens
so we've talked mainly about restricting
food in so-called overweight children
and the risk for long-term overeating
and eating disorders but what about
Force feeding the kids who are
underweight if you were on the smaller
side as a kid you probably were forced
to become part of the clean play Club
you know the whole finish what's on your
plate because kids are starving in
Africa story that everyone and their
grandmother used to throw at us and
listen I don't blame parents for this
tactic I'm a dietitian and feeding my
kids is probably one of the most
frustrating disheartening and honestly
traumatic parts of my day sometimes so I
fully get the tempting education to try
every bribe threat or game to get them
to eat but we know that this can
actually cause severe food aversions
negative associations and negative
emotions toward food not to mention
being told you must eat overrides
urinate body wisdom and intuition once
that he found that 70 of survey
participants experienced forced food
consumption in childhood with 49
reporting that they would cry 55
experiencing nausea and 20 actually
throwing up 72 percent of them said they
would never eat the forced food again
similarly another experimental study
found that children ate significantly
more food when not pressured to eat
compared to children who were pressure
to eat so as for the division of
responsibility which I discussed in my
video right here in order to encourage
children to become competent eaters our
role as parents is to determine the what
where and when of meal times and our
kids responsibility is to determine how
much or if they eat it all no Force
feeding no pressure no shaming no
catering just a hell of a lot of
patience and strapping yourself in for
the long game because I don't know about
you but I would rather my kids be open
to eating broccoli like all throughout
their Decades of adulthood then turning
them off veggies for life just to try to
sneak in a little vitamin C when they're
like four now how to appropriately
address kids weight is another huge
topic for another day but I will just
say that it should never be a discussion
made directly with your child if your
kid's doctor wants to talk about weight
ask her or him to do it when your child
is not in the room and if putting your
child on a diet is on the table consider
it an additive weight neutral approach
that will encourage Health promoting
behaviors without the shame stigma or
high risks of overt restriction my
Hunger cushion combo is a really great
place to start but let me know below if
you want a more thorough video on that
so if you've watched this video nodding
an acknowledgment of your own childhood
eating experiences I want you to first
try to have some compassion for those
who raised you remember that
generational diet culture runs deep but
if you're finding yourself falling into
some of those same patterns that your
parents fell victim to here are some key
tips to break the cycle number one reach
out for support we absolutely do not
have to do this alone and working with a
trained therapist or dietitian that
practices from a weight inclusive
approach can help us unpack and unlearn
these thoughts and behaviors before
they're passed down number two detox
your news feed in order to give up the
diet mentality we have to set boundaries
around the information that we consume
so don't be afraid to mute block or
unfollow content that's triggering and
not supportive to your health and
well-being number three find a
supportive Community whether it's online
or in person find a community of folks
with a similar Journey who Embraces an
inclusive approach to food and weight
and finally number four break free from
the diet cycle and tune into your
internal body wisdom by practicing
intuitive eating if you don't know where
to get started on this I have a whole
YouTube series where I go through every
principle in detail I also want to
reiterate again that disordered eating
overeating and eating disorders are
highly highly complex so this is
certainly not an exhaustive list of the
different factors that may have
influenced your relationship with food
but my hope here is that with continued
discourse around mental health and
childhood experiences that we can
collectively help each other unlearn
heal and break the cycle for generations
to come and on that note I hope you guys
like this video if you did be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on what or who you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
thank you